renewed fighting around the saporitian
nuclear power plant in the city of
enordar did not prevent the un nuclear
watchdog team from crossing the front
lines
in spite of the dangers the team led by
the international atomic energy director
rafael rossi moved ahead to begin the
much expected visit
grossi said he was able to inspect vital
equipment
i saw a lot and i have my people there
we were able to uh i was able to tour at
the whole site
moscow says kiev sent a sabotage team to
try to recover europe's largest nuclear
power plant that's been under russian
control since march
at 6 20 am two teams of ukrainian
saboteurs 60 men strong use seven speed
boats attempted to land on the banks of
the kahovka water reservoir some three
kilometers northeast of the zaparia
nuclear power plant
kiev denies all accusations and says
moscow is trying to manipulate the visit
and carried out attacks around the city
to terrorize the population and the
ukrainian employees inside the plant
their well-being is a major concern for
ukrainian officials
keith says one of its reactors had to be
shut down because of the shelling on
thursday and it warned about the
possibility of a meltdown if the plant
goes offline completely
the visit is expected to last for a few
days until the un team on the ground can
evaluate the dangers on site the
situation around the nuclear power plant
has had authorities here in kiev on the
edge as they're hoping russia will
demilitarize the area but russia has
already said it has no plans to remove
its troops anytime soon perez